welcome back from Mars you crazy Astro
masochist
okay it was actually just Hawaii but for
a full year these six scientists lived
in a Mars habitat simulator called high
seas on the Big Island high seas is an
example of international collaborative
research hosted and run by the
University of Hawaii so it's really
exciting to be able to welcome the crew
back to earth and back to Hawaii after a
year on Mars
did they science the SH out of it mark
Watney style they sure did they were
confined to their dome and only made
periodic journeys onto the volcanic
surface of Mauna Loa in their Martian
sim suits
hey nice kicks a mission tomorrow in
Zucco structure is realistic I think
technological and psychological
obstacles in this was the second longest
bar simulation ever undertaken that
honor belongs to a group of Russians who
spent 520 days in a pod and you thought
your roommate was lame
the u.s. research going up here is just
super vital when it comes to picking
crews figuring out how people are going
to actually work on different kinds of
missions it's sort of the human factors
element of space travel colonization the
crew was sealed off just like they would
be on Mars email was slowed to a Martian
20 minute delay and food power and water
were limited to what was on hand just
showing that it works you can actually
get water from the ground that is
seemingly dry it would work on Mars and
the implication is that you would be
able to get water on Mars from this
little greenhouse so what does a
returning Martian Explorer want to eat
pizza and bananas of course
you